Und ordentlich erklärt und eigentlich gibt es überhaupt nichts an diesem Video auszusetzen.
Eigentlich müssten das Video alle geil finden.
Ich meine, die Leute, die es gucken, scheinen es ja auch gut zu finden, die sich dafür interessieren.
Und es ist ja auch heute angesagt, aber Leute wollen nicht.
Da fragt man sich doch, warum man dann wirklich ordentlichen Content...
Ah, noch ein Diabom, ja, perfekt.
Warum man ordentlichen Content machen soll.
Mache ich einfach nur noch Battlefield-News-Videos.
Easy.
Mache ich einfach Battlefield-News-Videos jetzt.
Mache ich jede Woche zwei Battlefield-News-Videos, gibt es genug Zeug.
Oder mache ich Level-Cap 2.0-Sellout.
Easy, Abos.
Regenwolf, ja, ich erkläre das eigentlich ziemlich genau.
Ich meine, ein bisschen Vorkenntnisse muss man schon haben über das Ganze.
So, hier kann ich mir mal eine Dande kaufen am 14.
Wird auch echt...
Zeit.
Easy Dandel.
Warum bist du traurig?
Weil ich mir so viel Mühe gegeben habe für das Video heute.
Und das war eines der anstrengendsten Videos, die ich je aufgenommen habe.
Zumal ich sogar mehrere Anläufe noch gebraucht habe.
Und es ist sogar ein aktuelles Thema.
Das heißt, heute zu dem Thema noch wirklich ein inhaltlich ordentliches Video zu machen,
so ausführlich und so im Detail, ist wirklich nicht ohne gewesen.
Ja?
Aber, ich meine, ich bin ja erst im Prinzip um 17 Uhr von der Arbeit gekommen.
Ich habe mehrfach aufgenommen und insgesamt jetzt 28 Minuten Video hochgeladen bis jetzt.
Also ich war...
Ich habe heute im Prinzip noch nichts gemacht.
Ich habe eben gerade auch was gefunden.
Nichts großartig gemacht, außer das.
Und ich mache jetzt auch wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen Video-Stream-Nix.
Und, was kommt raus am Ende?
Also, dass es nicht unbedingt jeder guckt, kann ich ja verstehen.
Aber gleich erstmal 5D-Abos reingehauen.
Ja?
Ja.
Also, ihr müsst mir jetzt kein Geld geben oder so, ne?
Aber, wer hat denn gewusst...
Ja, Woodpecker, 1556, 10,51 Euro.
Du bist der erstbeste YouTuber, den ich kenne.
Ja, das höre ich natürlich gerne, so was.
Aber das nervt mich, weil mich das wieder zu dem Schluss bringt,
dass du eigentlich, wenn du irgendwas gefunden hast, von dem du merkst,
oder, sag mal so, entweder findest du was,
wovon du merkst, dass
das gut ankommt
und reitest dann ewig drauf rum
oder du bist noch unkreativer und suchst dir was
was gut ankommt und reitest dann immer drauf rum
so Reaction-Videos
oder irgendwie sowas
im Prinzip will gar keiner mehr
ordentliche Sachen sehen
habe ich manchmal das Gefühl
ich gebe zu
meine Pain-Skills sind jetzt echt nicht die besten
oder so, aber zum erklären
reicht das doch
und ich habe sogar ein schönes Thumbnail gemacht
ich habe mir übrigens für Thumbnails
habe ich mir Dings hier gekauft
wie heißt es? Affinity Designer
das ist echt gut
weil ich brauche für Thumbnails ja kein Photoshop
oder sowas, das ist ja absolut Overkill
oder auch kein InDesign und sonst was
Affinity Designer
Affinity Designer ist super
wow, bisschen laut hier
der Klaviertyp
habe ich mir gekauft, weiß ich was es gekostet hat, 69 Euro oder so
50 Euro, sind wir doch so laut
so
und wo war ich jetzt?
hat stehen geblieben, keine Ahnung
ja, Affinity Designer ist echt cool
äh, BDO ist ein bisschen leiser, ne?
das ist eigentlich mein Gaul
Lull
ist nicht da
weiß nicht, wo ich den abgeste...
ah, da, da steht er doch
was ist das hier eigentlich, haben die neue Icons?
oh, Buffwood muss ich noch kaufen
Buffwood, richtig
Buffwood
ich glaube, ich mache den Titel mal wieder anders
weil ich habe mich jetzt ja ausgeheult, jetzt reicht es
aber das geht mir echt auf den Sack
oder man geht nach Japan
und filmt die schönen Wälder, ja
oh, was ein...
wie sie sich aufgeregt haben, alle wieder
ich habe das Video übrigens nicht geguckt
ich finde es überraschend, dass sich ein paar D-Abos trüben
was ist da dran überraschend?
man gibt sich übelst Mühe
und lädt was hoch
was man selbst gut findet
und ist davon überzeugt, gibt sich Mühe
und du siehst erst mal, es finden Leute scheiße
ja, warum sollte mich das nicht betrümen?
laut Socialplate hast du heute 33 Abos gemacht
richtig, habe ich
ich habe die letzten Tage relativ viele Abos gemacht
aber was du auf Socialplate natürlich nicht siehst
ist, was ab dem Upload-Zeitpunkt ist
die Abos habe ich ja heute Vormittag gemacht
stellst du jetzt schon auf Socialplate
um zu gucken, ob das stimmt, was ich erzähle
oder was?
lol
ich wollte Food kaufen, was muss ich denn eigentlich für Food kaufen?
Mediamiel muss ich kaufen
ich mache den Titel mal anders
ich mache jetzt mal irgendeinen
Ultimativer
Daily Quest
Debate
ach, keine Ahnung
ich weiß keinen Titel
gerade
hat er jetzt den Titel
das backt übelst rum auf Twitch
ich ändere den Titel und er ändert den Titel nicht
auch geil
Magoria, ne
Mediamiel brauche ich
da, give please
ne, ein Sandburg-Tutorial
würden sich wahrscheinlich mehr Leute angucken und geil finden
oh, jetzt haben wir schon
den ersten Aussprache-Flamer
am Start
der sich darüber aufregt, dass ich das
das B oftmals als P ausspreche
das mache ich eigentlich schon immer
der hat jetzt noch gefehlt, ey
Hi Max, weißt, äh, was, ähm
ich weiß nicht, warum, aber
ich bekomme bei Black Desert immer nach kurzer Zeit Kopfschmerzen
weißt du, an welchen Grafikeinstellungen das liegen kann?
Ja, mach das Kamerashaking aus
Kamerashaking
und, ähm
die Zaubereffekte
kannst du auch ein bisschen runter, runter
machen
give energy
nice
ja, energy ist immer gut
mach die, wie gesagt, mach die Grafik
ich zeig dir das gleich mal
ich das bei mir hab
ähm
ja, guck mal
mach die
ist jetzt eigentlich der Titel geändert mal mittlerweile
ja
ok, ähm
mach die, mach die Grafikeffekte
hier unten, also mach das hier weg
Kamerashaking-Effex
äh, Effeks
Kamerashaking-Settings und das ganzen Scheiß
macht es weg das nervt und effekt transparency auf 50 prozent das sieht dann ungefähr so aus
wenn du wenn du ein spell machst vom wizard sieht es dann auch so aus so leicht transparent
es reicht dass du siehst aber es ist nicht so so in your face es reicht aber dass du siehst
und was mir auch immer auf den zack geht ist das ist das geschreie von den von den helden und das
kann man hier auch irgendwo ausschalten weil hier irgendwie ich glaube das ist es bei den
video schreien alle helden so übertrieben rum wenn sie irgendwas machen es mag ja dass das
verfahren gibt schon lange das hat aber fakt das hat aber im prinzip noch mehr overhead als das
was ich erklärt habe was jetzt machen wollen also prinzip ist es ähnlich du musst halt jedes mal die
komplette tabelle switchen das macht das ist natürlich noch mal ein bisschen anstrengender
ja aber im prinzip kannst
du das so machen und so ähnlich machen sie es jetzt ja auch du schmeißt halt die ganze
kölner die die ganze kölner geschichte wirfst du aus dem virtuellen adressraum für deine prozesse
weg so ich wollte jetzt schon ist eigentlich also der daily daily stellt machen ich will
auf das pferd steigen video lassen lasst mich auf das pferd steigen daily ich war mal ich verkaufe
ich verkaufe den krempel garten nochmal wenn ich schon dabei bin erst mal alles schön einsammeln
schon kollekten wie in der kirche oder lieber toll collect als die campel hier rein sagt sagen
dass ich nix nix falsch ist sälle das behalten wir alles den scheiß was nicht und wenn es braucht
das legt man in wald rhein habe ich auf platz im ort ich mache oder fand ein paar daily sich war
eigentlich wollte ich das alleine machen aber ich hab mir gedacht hey wenn ich jetzt noch ein paar
dailies waren ein paar mobs kloppe dann kann ich eigentlich von mir das mal machen weil ich jetzt
voraus wie man machen kann bisschen schwätzen beste aber stellst gehen wir
mal hoch das machen meine pets meine pets müssen gefiedert werden ein video
bist du immer erst mal mit 3000 sachen beschäftigt vor der anfangen kannst
asia klein stellt halt alle server anbieter die mit intel arbeiten also ich
gehe mal davon aus die venture den kram eingespielt haben aber für je nach
anwendung ist es halt keine gute also je nachdem hast du halt entweder
performance einbußen oder sicherheitsprobleme also eigentlich
würde ich sagen gut für server anbieter die epic verwenden
die haben nämlich das problem nicht was ist das für ein trend mit not hot
wie es gibt wirklich jemand im internet der den scheiß noch nicht mitgekriegt
hat also wo ist mein pferd abgestellt ich bin
übrigens vergesslich
ey
also es gibt glaube ich irgendwie denn was ist das in englischen komiker der so
auf rapper macht und er hat halt ein video aufgenommen wie er da einen seiner
songs vor vorgetragen hat im studio und der song hat halt einmal irgendwie den
ganz lustigen text und merkwürdige geräusche und seitdem geht halt das
ganze internet darauf ab du suchst einfach mal mensch not hot auf youtube
wenn er wollt können wir uns heute wir uns looken wir uns in die textur von vdo
die texturen an sich sind eigentlich gar nicht so übel ich muss mich kurz
gucken auf was ist gestellt habe ich glaube ich habe es oft hoch texta die
die texturen an sich sind gar nicht so schlecht wenn man hier mal gucken wird
Texturen an sich sind gar nicht so schlecht, wenn man hier mal guckt.
Das Problem ist einmal, meine, naja gut, das ist jetzt echt mega kacke, ne.
Aber es gibt welche, die sind echt ganz okay, ja.
Aber das Problem ist, dass Video übelst Sachen einploppen.
Das ist das, was scheiße aussieht.
Ey, man, das hat bestimmt jetzt nicht die besten Texturen oder so, das Game.
Aber guck mal nach da hinten, wie die Bäume da aufploppen und so.
Quick Muffs.
Nice.
Ich weiß zwar nicht, was ich damit genau mache.
Ich hab da ganz viele.
Da gibt's Gifts.
Gifts, Gifts, immer gut.
Nice, nice Gifts.
BigShark.
Also, weil du es ja noch nicht kennst.
Während ich reite...
Wobei, eigentlich hab ich keinen Bock, mir das nochmal anzugucken.
Such einfach MenstrualHot auf YouTube.
Das bekannteste dürfte das hier sein.
Wart mal.
Moment, ich bin zu spät im Video.
Ja, das bekannteste ist wahrscheinlich das hier.
So, das ist so das bekannteste aus diesem ganzen MenstrualHot-BigShark-Zeug.
BigShark.
Und das kam so gut an, dass da halt zig Leute irgendwelche Meme-Bilder und Gedulds gemacht haben.
Jetzt ist halt keiner hot, der cool sein will.
Weil er ist ja halt auch cool und nicht hot.
Es hat übrigens für mich eine ganze Weile gedauert, bis ich das gecheckt habe.
Dass MenstrualHot quasi eine Umschreibung dafür ist, dass er cool ist.
Irgendwie war ich in dieser Rap-Denkweise nicht so richtig drinnen.
Irgendwann hatte ich dann die Erleuchtung, er ist not hot, weil er halt so cool ist.
Mein Ex-Buch ist ausgelaufen.
Oder auch so aus.
So, wir reiten uns jetzt hier oben.
Wir machen jetzt Daily, Daily, wir machen...
Moment, also.
Wir machen Daily jetzt da und da und eventuell da.
Also, im Prinzip einfach auf dieser Ecke hier.
Fangen wir mal mit der Daily hier an, würde ich sagen.
Komm, wir fangen mit der Basi, mit der Basi, mit der Basi-Daily fangen wir an.
Ich sehe gerade das Video.
Also, ich glaube, mein Stream, der ruckelt nicht.
Das ist einfach BDO, das ruckelt, wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe.
Ich gucke nämlich gerade noch mal eine Stream-Vorschau.
Ne, das Stream ist flüssig, das ist einfach BDO, was ruckelt.
Das ist halt BDO.
Was willst du machen?
Füttern wir mal den China-Farmer, den Pleb und den RNG-Stream.
Ja, ne, ne, ich habe es gesehen, das ruckelt nicht.
Das ist einfach BDO, was kurz ruckelt.
BDO hast du halt einfach auch mal Frame-Props von 144 auf 35.
Das ist bestimmt Meltdown.
Das ist bestimmt der Windows-Meltdown-Fix.
Das muss so sein.
War ja vorher bei BDO noch nie.
Oh, fuck, was ist mit meinem Stream los?
What the fuck?
Moment, ich muss mal mein Audio-Interface rausnehmen.
Das klingt mega, das klingt ja mal richtig kaputt.
Was ist das?
Auf meinem Streaming-Rechner ist der Windows-Sound gerade übelst am abkacken.
Aber richtig am abkacken.
Das hört ihr nicht.
Seid froh, dass ihr das nicht hört.
Das ist auf einem anderen Rechner.
Das ist ja gar nicht mein Streaming-Rechner.
Das war jetzt falsch ausgedrückt.
Da, wo ich halt, während ich hier auf dem Rechner spiele, Internet fast gucken kann, Chat habe und sowas.
Boah, ist der Sound kaputt.
Das hört sich an wie, irgendwie, wie eine Ente in Slow-Motion, der Sound.
Den muss ich jetzt mal neu starten.
Spielst du in Full-HD, Max?
Ja.
Immer.
Jetzt geht der Sound wieder.
Ja, wie, wie, genau.
Nicht Studio 28.
Genauso hat sich das angehört.
Genauso, genauso wie du das gerade geschrieben hast.
Aber jetzt ist der Sound wieder okay.
Schlechtes Matchmaking-Overwatch liegt an Meltdown.
Ja.
Was ist das eigentlich für Gedudel im Hintergrund?
Das ist Best of Hiroyama, nee, Hi-Hiruma.
Der Japaner spricht es wahrscheinlich Hiruma oder so aus.
Die Japaner sprechen das alles immer so geil aus, so zackig.
Hiruma.
Ich weiß noch nicht, wie man den Typ ausspricht.
Also, es war was Entspannendes.
Wir können ja auch.
Warte, muss ich mal raussuchen.
Nee, wir lassen, ich lasse die Musik jetzt erstmal.
Das ist irgendwie schön entspannt.
No happy meal for you.
Genau, ganz bestimmt.
Okay.
Hihi.
Moin Max, hast du eine Ahnung, ob man mit 250 Ohm-Kopfhörern niemanden fürs Zocken benutzt,
beziehungsweise allgemein für PC eine zusätzliche Soundkarte,
beziehungsweise Kopfhörer-Verstärker benötigt bei seinem PC?
Kommt auf deine Soundkarte an.
Bei den meisten Onboard-Soundkarten würde ich mal vermuten,
dass es...
Ich hab's noch nie ausprobiert, ehrlich gesagt,
aber ich würde mal sagen,
wenn was rauskommt, ist es nicht so geil.
Wahrscheinlich viel zu leise.
Also an einem iPhone kannst du es definitiv vergessen, zu betreiben.
Ganz komplett kommt gar nichts raus.
Ich hab hier an meiner Headset-Wand noch einen AKG 701.
Da muss ich mal kurz gucken, wie viel Widerstand der hat.
62.
So, und der hat an Smartphones und Tablets schon richtige Probleme.
Ich hab ihn an der Onboard-Soundkarte aber noch nicht ausprobiert.
Okay.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn du einen mit 250 hast,
dass das da aus der Onboard-Soundkarte, wenn man allzu viel rauskommt,
und da schon ein Kopfhörer-Verstärker mit ein bisschen Wumms nicht verkehrt wäre.
So, weil je nach Onboard-Soundkarte
sind da ja auch die digitalen Analog-Wandler und sowas
nicht unbedingt die besten.
Und isoliert ist es auch nicht gut.
Aber da gibt's richtig krasse Qualitätsunterschiede zwischen den Mainboards
und es gibt mittlerweile auch ganz gute.
Die DT770, nehmen die klein.
Dann kannst du es auf jeden Fall überall dran betreiben.
Höhö, hat Bumsen gesagt.
Ich kann auch Fisten sagen.
Dumm-Fisten.
Hey Max, ich hab gerade deinen Witt gesehen.
Ist echt super.
Hab's als Obertechnik-Loop eigentlich gut verstanden.
Das freut mich zu hören.
Weil ich war ja schon ein bisschen geknickt über das Video, muss ich sagen.
Also, beziehungsweise, dass ich gleich mal instant D-Abos gekriegt hab.
Mal gucken.
Mal gucken, wie es heute Morgen früh aussieht mit Abos, die ich bekommen hab.
Es schwankt.
Es schwankt aktuell.
Aktuell kriege ich Abos, kriege ich wieder D-Abos.
Jetzt bin ich wieder auf insgesamt nur Minus 4.
Es kamen wieder ein paar dabei.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, ich mein vielleicht,
vielleicht wird das Video ja mal wirklich in,
ich hab's extra in diese Technik und Dings,
wie heißt diese Kategorie?
Science and Technology oder so gesetzt.
Auf YouTube.
Wissenschaft und Technik, genau.
Trifft's ja ganz gut.
Und vielleicht hab ich ja Glück
und irgendjemand bei YouTube stellt fest,
dass ich jetzt mal ein bisschen mehr Zeit habe.
Und ich hab's extra in diese Technik und Dings, wie heißt diese Kategorie?
Science and Technology oder so gesetzt.
Das ist vom Content her gar nicht so schlecht
und empfiehlt das ein bisschen.
Der Sibaro ist auch da.
Easy Clap.
Genauso wie Optik Jellyfish das sagt.
Ich würd mir auch einen
ordentlichen Verstärker holen.
Oder eben den
Kopfhörer mit
niedriger, wie sagen sie dazu,
Impendanz.
Also mit niedrigerem Widerstand.
Den Unterschied wirst du nicht so viel hören.
Willst du gar nicht hören.
Bin ich jetzt eigentlich da?
Ah ja, ich bin da.
Ich kann Dailies machen.
Yeah.
Ihr findet ja eigentlich das Thumbnail.
Ich find das Thumbnail vom neuen Video ist irgendwie schick.
Das sieht gut aus.
Das ist nicht übelst überzogen
irgendwie mit roten Kreisen und so.
Aber ich denk trotzdem, dass das dazu anregt
drauf zu klicken.
So, Quest.
Unsubscribing Max heißt die Quest.
Easy. Machen wir.
Hier.
Ähm, das bei Gear ist richtig.
Was da steht, das einzige, was noch dazu gekommen ist,
dass ich jetzt meine Waffe
mal ultimatet hab.
Aber das Beste ist, hab ich euch ja noch gar nicht gezeigt.
Hier.
Ah, es gibt wieder neue Gilden-Rewards.
Ähm, und ein Pilz?
Oder was ist das? Kucku.
Irgendein Pet.
Äh, hier gibt's Dande.
Easy Dande gibt's hier.
Hab ich 70 Seals zusammen.
Quasi am 17.
Wenn ich das richtig gerechnet hab.
Sind eigentlich alle Questen.
Quest Daily, nein, nein.
Nein, nein, nein, sind nicht alle Quests Daily.
Es gibt Weekly Quests, Daily Quests und auch einmalige Quests.
Pro Charakter einmalig,
soweit ich weiß.
Oder?
Ja, doch, muss pro Charakter.
Ja, ja, muss pro Charakter sein.
Es gibt die Main Quest, die ist definitiv pro Charakter.
So, äh.
Brauch ich denn jetzt Critical Hit Rate?
Jawoll.
Max FTW I.
Das ist ein guter Name.
Warum I? War Max FTW schon belegt?
Ähm.
Ähm, schreibt, das Video ist großartig, hab's gut verstanden, aber welches Genie kommt bitte darauf, dass es jedes Mal faszinierend ist, wie die Leute die Sicherheit umgehen und ausnutzen.
Also da drauf zu kommen ist echt geil.
Ich mein, an sich ist ja nichts verkehrt, ne?
Es funktioniert ja alles so wie gedacht.
Das Design ist halt scheiße.
Deswegen hat Linus auch gleich mal wieder schön inter geflamed.
Das kann er ja gut.
Leute flamen.
Aber die finden können das generell gut, Leute flamen.
Das Design ist scheiße.
Es funktioniert ja prinzipiell alles wie gedacht.
Du kommst ja nur drauf, indem du misst, was schnellere Zugriffszeiten hat.
Keks not hot, Timo.
Never hot.
Kann ich noch so viel T-Shirts an- und ausziehen.
Der Einzige, der hot ist, ist der Wizard.
Das ist übrigens lustig, finde man diese Daily Quest.
Ich soll Basis killen, aber ich kann nicht irgendwelche anderen Fischer killen, die auch Basis sind, aber offensichtlich keine sind.
Das ist aber BDO-Logik, da muss man, muss man nichts drauf geben.
Was soll man als normaler...
Bob gegen die Exploits der CPU-Unternehmen, äh, Patches installieren?
Man muss halt sagen, die Patches sind halt nur Workarounds.
Wirklich fixen können das nur die Hersteller.
Und die Workarounds führen halt dazu, dass bei Intel-CPUs bisschen Performance-Einbußen gibt.
Aber bei den meisten Sachen ist das...
Rechne ich nicht damit, dass das großartige Auswirkungen haben wird.
Was ich mich übrigens frage ist, müssen wir mal nachrechnen.
Ich, weil wenn prinzipiell die Speicherverwaltung geändert wird...
Könnte das durchaus auch AMD betreffen.
Also sprich, dass dadurch, dass ein Intel-Bug umgangen wird, äh, auch AMD-CPUs langsamer sind.
Es sei denn, man hat eine Abfrage eingebaut.
Also sprich, wenn AMD-CPU drinne ist, dann aktiviert man das nicht.
Dann muss man halt beide Verfahren pflegen.
Der Frasier ist am Start.
Guck mal hier, easy Basis grind. Also eigentlich dieses easy Daily Quest.
Aber easy...
Also ich mein, da verbinden wir ja zwei gute Sachen mit.
Man verbindet easy Basis grind mit easy Daily Quest.
Ich muss gucken, ob ich wieder D-Abos gekriegt hab.
Das triggert mich übelst gerade.
Ne, ich hab wieder welche dazugekommen.
Ey, jetzt bin ich bei plus minus null wieder.
Yeah!
Hat mich jemand zufällig abonniert aus dem Stream gerade?
Vielleicht kommt es ja jetzt...
Vielleicht kommt es jetzt ja von hier, weil ich hier gerade rumgeheult hab.
Haha, wie scheiße das ist.
THX, Timo, Timo, Timo wahrscheinlich eher.
Sind AMDs CPUs...
Sind AMDs CPUs also jetzt besser als die von Intel?
Da ändert sich nichts dran.
Also...
Wenn du ganz spezielle Anwendungen hast, dann vielleicht...
Sind... Können auch...
Also wenn du ne Anwendung hast, wo früher ne Intel-CPU schneller war und das so ein Grenzfall ist, könnte sich dann da lohnen.
Aber bei Spielen werden auch nach wie vor Intel-CPUs, die aktuelle Generation, ja, noch schneller sein als AMD.
Bei den meisten Spielen.
Kommst da, Anzeige ist raus.
Gleich gibt's...
Bamm!
Dis-Abo gibt's dann hier.
Übrigens, das war jetzt ja die erste Woche, wo ich wieder arbeiten gehen musste.
Und was ich bei mir witzig finde, ist jedes Mal, jedes Mal, wenn ich lange Urlaub hab, und ich mach das ja jedes Jahr so.
Ich hab ja jedes Jahr quasi den ganzen, oder fast den ganzen Dezember Urlaub.
Jedes Mal denk ich mir dann so, boah, du hast überhaupt keinen Bock nächste Woche auf die Arbeit zu gehen.
Absolut null.
Und überleg mir dann immer, ey, komm, mach doch hier mal, hör doch mal, lass den Scheiß doch.
Und mach mal hier dein Online-Zeug professionell.
Aber ich entscheide mich dann doch jedes Mal dagegen.
Was auch die, was auch, was auch so rational gesehen die bessere Entscheidung ist.
Also nicht unbedingt wegen der Kohle, sondern weil's einfach...
Teilweise gezwungen wird dann.
Ja, und so bin ich in beiden Sachen ziemlich entspannt.
Weil ich mein, so weiß ich, wenn ich gar nichts mehr auf YouTube machen will, hab ich immer noch genug Geld.
Erstens hab ich genug gespart, zweitens geh ich arbeiten vier Tage und krieg noch genug.
Und auf der Arbeit bin ich entspannt, weil ich mir denke, ihr könnt mich alle mal, wenn's mir auf den Sack geht.
Deswegen ist es total bescheuert.
Aber jedes Mal, wenn ich lang Urlaub hab...
Ich hab dich abonniert, deine Werbung eben war nicht schlecht.
Na, wie ist das denn?
Hat so was gebracht hier?
Ich muss mir angewöhnen.
Ich muss, ich muss regelmäßig...
Ich muss regelmäßig Sellout machen.
Ich muss, ich muss alle, ich muss alle Stunden hier im Stream mal drauf hinweisen.
So nach dem Motto...
Ähm...
Und wenn ihr immer auf dem aktuellsten Stand sein wollt, dann folgt mir doch auf Twitter, auf YouTube, auf weiß was nicht, irgendwie sowas.
So wie das die richtig, die richtigen Sellout Pros machen.
Und ich brauch noch T-Shirts und Energydrinks.
Und was braucht, was braucht man noch alles so für richtigen, für maximalen Sellout?
Was ist denn da so angesagt?
Shampoo?
Äh, Haarwaschmittel?
Haarwaschmittel?
Brauch ich?
Also, äh, eigenes, eigenes Max, Max Shampoo, ja?
Und die Glocke für die Notification.
Die Max Handyhülle?
Ja, ja, alles, alles brauch ich.
Ich kann den...
Ich könnte echt, das ist eine gute Idee, Max FTW.
Ich könnte den Nightbot so einmal in der Stunde spammen lassen.
Einen Song.
Ja, da hab ich ja schon den passenden Frankfurter Produzent am Start hier.
Der macht das.
Heute ist es eh egal, ob du singen kannst.
Geschweige denn, ob du, ob du rappen kannst.
Das ist wurscht.
Nicht, nicht, weil es die Musik besser macht oder so.
Aber es juckt keinen mehr, ob die Musik gut ist oder nicht.
Ach, da sind ja keine Webs zu bashen.
Basis sind auch noch gar nicht fertig.
Warum, warum geh ich hier raus?
Patreon, das hab ich mir schon überlegt.
Das hab ich mir schon überlegt, ob ich das machen soll.
Weil das ist ein guter Weg, ohne dass ich jetzt irgendwie noch zusätzlich G2A-Sellout oder so in so einen Mist machen muss.
G2A hab ich ja, hab ich, hab ja gesagt, hab ich keinen Bock mehr.
Ähm...
Das war wirklich eine ganz gute Geschichte.
Das hab ich mir schon überlegt, ob ich das nicht machen soll.
Aber ihr kennt mich ja, wenn ich mir sowas überlege, dauert es immer ewig, bis ich das mal mache.
Also wirklich ewig.
Snapchat, ich hab noch, ich hab noch nicht mal Snapchat.
Ich kann kein Snapchat-Sellout machen.
Ich hab ja, ich hab ja auch nur Facebook.
Weil das, nicht weil ich Facebook geil finde oder irgendwie auf Facebook großartig was, was machen will.
Sondern einfach nur, weil das mit die einfachste Möglichkeit ist, viele Leute zu erreichen.
Und ich hab's schon, ich hab schon so oft in Videos gesagt, ne.
Ich kenne niemanden, der Facebook gut findet.
Also Facebook, irgendwie verwendet jeder Facebook, weil halt viele Leute auf Facebook sind.
Aber keiner benutzt gerne Facebook.
Und ganz viele Leute machen das auch so auf Sparflamme mittlerweile.
So nach dem Motto, ich bin halt bei Facebook, wenn doch noch irgendeiner was will.
Aber die haben alle keinen Bock mehr auf Facebook.
Bin ich froh, dass ich mit dem Scheiß nie angefangen hab.
Facebook ist der größte Shit überhaupt, ey.
Braucht kein Mensch.
Und nervt eigentlich nur.
Mittlerweile auch gleich.
Ja, ich kenn viele.
Also, es sagen viele.
Ich les das immer oft, dass Leute, einfach Facebook kommt weg.
Was ich noch nie verstanden hab, ist, warum es Snapchat gibt.
Wahrscheinlich ist die einzige Daseinsberechtigung von Snapchat aktuell, weil es Snapchat-Filter gibt.
Und das die Leute irgendwie lustig finden.
Wozu braucht man Snapchat?
Ich mein jetzt, ich mein die Frage jetzt wirklich ernst.
Ich will keinen Flamen, der Snapchat verwendet.
Wozu ist das?
Also ursprünglich war das ja mal, dass ähm,
dass man Nachrichten quasi löschen konnte, in Anführungsstrichen.
Also sprich, dass man,
dass man Schwanzbilder und Tittenbilder verschicken konnte.
Und sich ein-
Das ist im Prinzip das, was der Fabian grad schreibt.
Er kennt sich da anscheinend aus.
Und, dass man denken konnte, sie werden gelöscht.
Ich mein, sie waren nie weg, aber man hat gedacht, sie sind weg.
Ja, das ist der einzige Grund, der mir auch einfällt.
Dass sich Leute Nacktbilder schicken können.
Aber anscheinend verwenden ja auch viele Leute so Snapchat.
Und ich wei-
Warum?
Also, was hat-
Warum gibt's das?
Also, ich muss sagen, seit es Discord gibt,
sind meine sämtlichen, ähm, Chat und Chat, Video, Telefonie, Telefonie, ähm,
Aufnahmesachen mit mehreren Leuten, sind alle mit Discord wunderbar ab-
Abgefackelt, ja?
Wenn du so fragst, versteh ich gar nicht mehr, warum du Snapchat benutzt.
Ja, ich glaub, das wissen viele irgendwie nicht so.
Also, ich hab-
Ich frag mich-
Ich frag mich echt, was man da-
Was man damit macht.
Also, warum es das gibt.
Vor allem, warum sich das so durchgesetzt hat.
Ja, genau.
Das kenn ich auch.
Die Leute, die Snapchat-Filter verwenden.
Und irgendwie denken, das wär die oberkrasse Bildbearbeitung.
Auf Snapchat sind die meisten Grills.
Achso.
Das ist natürlich ein Grund.
Das kann man verstehen, wenn man da auf der Suche ist.
Ich dachte, bei Tinder sind die meisten Grills.
Übrigens, ich hab letztens gesehen, dass-
Ich hab letztens gesehen, es gibt auch das Kappa-Bride-Gegenstück von Tinder.
Nennt sich Grindr.
Grindr.
Und wisst ihr-
Ich hab auch noch was Schönes letztens auf Twitter gesehen.
Von einer Feministin, die hat-
Oh, jetzt kommt wieder-
Jetzt ist wieder ganz, ganz-
Thema, wo gleich hier wieder alle sich aufregen können.
Von einer Feministin, die hat gesagt-
Sie schreibt nicht mehr das Wort Woman, sondern sie schreibt Womin.
Weil im Wort Woman steckt Men drinnen.
Und sie verwendet das Wort-
Sie will keine Wörter verwenden, wo Men drin vorkommt.
Dementsprechend ist Woman ja absolut schon quasi grenzwertig sexistisch.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Die Leute haben echt Probleme.
Ich mein, wenn man sich vorstellt, dass man das-
Ich mein, so schreibt man das.
Was soll das sein?
Das hört sich an wie ein Mob in BDO.
Ja, was grindest du heute?
Womin.
Das konnte man jetzt auch auf zwei Arten verstehen.
So war es gar nicht gedacht.
Ach ja, und-
Könnt ihr euch noch an diesen Skandal um Tracer erinnern?
Als rausgekommen ist, dass Tracer lesbisch ist.
In diesem einen Weihnachtscomic.
Von Overwatch.
Kann sich da noch jemand dran erinnern?
Das war letztes Jahr.
Letztes-
Letztes Jahr zu Weihnachten ist ein Overwatch-Weihnachtscomic rausgekommen.
Wo man gesehen hat, dass Tracer eine Freundin hat.
Also eine Womin, quasi.
Und da war natürlich klar-
Und die haben dann auch rumge-
Also, rumgeknut.
Die haben sich geküsst im Comic.
Und-
Da war halt klar, Tracer is gay.
So, und-
Man könnte auch sagen, dass Tracer gay ist.
Also, man könnte sagen, dass Tracer gay ist.
So, und-
Man könnte jetzt ja denken-
Dass-
Dass begrüßt wird.
Dass dann viele sagen-
Boah, Blizzard-
Irgendwie mutig.
Find ich gut.
Dass quasi euer-
Euer Aushängeschild-
Dass ihr quasi sagt, hey, die ist lesbisch und so.
Eigentlich-
Eigentlich hätte ich gedacht, dass dann eben die, die sich über sowas immer aufregen, dass sie das gut finden.
So.
Und-
Wisst ihr, was das Argument war, warum das nicht gut ist?
Das finde ich, ist so hängen geblieben.
Das kann ich nicht wirklich nachvollziehen.
Ähm-
Sie haben sich dann darüber beschwert, dass, ähm, Tracer ein-
Ein Charakter ist, der explizit für das männliche Auge designt ist.
Und dann ist es schlecht.
Was?
Hätten sie jetzt Saria genommen, hätten sie sich beschwert, so nach dem Motto-
Ja, ja, wieder die ganz-
Wieder die alten stereotypischen Sachen ausgepackt.
Äh-
Hate, hate, hate.
Und dann nimmt man Tracer, so quasi eines der Aushängeschilder und so quasi hübschesten Charaktere in Overwatch, so-
Dann ist das auch nicht, weil das explizit für das männliche Auge designt ist.
Also die-
Es gibt echt Leute, die können sich den ganzen Tag über alles aufregen.
Ich hab das Gefühl, da geht's auch schon lange nicht mehr irgendwie um Gleichberechtigung, sondern einfach um sich aufzuregen.
Saria ist viel attraktiver als Tracer.
Ich sag ja immer jedem das seine.
Tracer müsste auch nicht sein.
Mei-
Mei ist bestes Overwatch-Grill.
Mei ist beste.
Alles von allen Overwatch-Grills ist-
Da ist Mei eindeutig mein Favorit.
Und mich wundert es nicht, dass das erste, was es zu Overwatch gegeben hat, so quasi an, nennen wir es mal Fan-Content, irgendwelche Porns waren.
Das wundert mich überhaupt gar nicht, ja.
Noch während der Beta, ey.
Was? Max steht auf dicke Mädchen?
Naja, ich sag mal so.
Es muss ja immer passen, ne?
Und ich mein, ich bin jetzt nicht mega fett oder so, aber ich bin auch nicht das schlankste.
Aber das muss ja schon passen zusammen.
Und Mei ist halt- Mei ist top.
Da kann man nichts gegen sagen.
Sick, genau.
Super sick.
Am besten-
Am besten sah Mei immer noch aus in diesem Animations- in diesem Shortfilm.
Das haben sie echt gut hingekriegt.
Wie viele Barsis muss ich denn eigentlich noch killen?
Letzter Barsi!
Barsi, easy life!
Ich guck jetzt mal, ich muss jetzt mal in die Comments von meinem Video gucken, ja.
Ob da jetzt- ob da jetzt-
Irgendwie wieder der Rechtschreib-Flamer wieder am Start ist von vorher.
Äh.
So, ähm, dann gehen wir mal Quest abgeben.
Vor allem hab ich das jetzt richtig ausgesprochen, eigentlich.
Quest!
Geht das?
Alter, mein Quest geht nicht.
Man muss immer so- Quest.
Aber bei Quest, bei- WTF, Moment.
Autorun.
Autorun, Fail.
Bei Quest ist das egal, aber bei Minecraft ist das nicht egal, oder?
Das muss immer-
Quest!
Heißen.
NA-Wegfindung.
Um jetzt mal dieses etwas merkwürdige Thema, um dem noch was hinzuzufügen.
Neben Mei, find ich in Overwatch, find ich auch noch-
Wer- wer- wer fast an Mei rankommt in Overwatch,
ist Anna.
Allerdings-
Ich hab jetzt absichtlich mal Pause gemacht.
Allerdings mit dem- mit dem- mit dem Junge-Anna-Skin.
Ähm.
Kann man in BDO alles skillen, oder sollte man sich für bestimmte Skills entscheiden?
Du kannst prinzipiell alles skillen, wenn du genug Punkte hast.
Also du wirst früher oder später, ähm, genug Punkte haben.
Aber, das dauert.
Du musst ganz schön grinden, okay?
Du musst ganz schön grinden, um wirklich alles skillen zu können.
Und ich würde von-
Ich würde eigentlich gar nicht so sehr meine Punkte aus dem Fenster hauen.
Aber du kannst bis 55, soweit ich weiß, kannst du skillen, wie du willst.
Mit 55, also bis 55.
Oder was?
56?
Weiß ich nicht, aber kannst du umskillen.
Das heißt, du kannst es eigentlich ausprobieren.
Weil ab 56 kriegst du noch eine zweite Skill-Linie.
Also aktuell hast du ja nur die hier.
Main.
Und dann kriegst du noch Awakening.
Und du musst eigentlich hauptsächlich erstmal das hier skillen.
In Awakening.
Das heißt, du brauchst dann mit 56 auch ordentlich viele Skill-Points.
Von diesen normalen Skills, ähm, hat man dann nur noch ein paar.
Außer halt die, die richtig viele Skill-Punkte haben und die richtig krassen PvP-Roxer sind.
Die haben auch von den alten Skills noch mehr.
Und 80 Hotbars.
So, wir haben Quest abgegeben.
Dann können wir jetzt...
Katri Spot reiten, oder?
Wo gehen wir am besten hin?
Ja, Katri Spot.
Da hatte ich den Friseur mit dem Spiel angesteckt.
Es geht.
Ich bin ja, ich bin halt der übelste BDO-Casual, ne?
Und vor allem, was mich jetzt ein bisschen motiviert, auch...
Naja, wenn nicht täglich, aber fast täglich, halt mein, mein...
Daily und bisschen rumzukrinden und sowas, ist halt, weil ich streamen kann.
Centaur best, meinst du ich mach...
Dann machen wir Centaur-Quests.
Das ist halt viel, viel entspannter.
Also erstens, glaube ich, zum Zugucken ist BDO relativ entspannt.
Das ist jetzt, das ist jetzt ja im Prinzip kein Overwatch, wo permanent irgendwas ist oder Battlefield oder so.
Ist relativ entspannt.
Außer es kommen wieder irgendwelche Noob-Bersis, wie letztens am Gaha-Spot.
Ach, das war, das war der echt, das war der größte Kack-Berser, den ich je gesehen habe.
Der war so schlecht.
Der, der war so schlecht.
Ich mein...
Ich hab überhaupt keine Moves gemacht im Endeffekt, ne?
Und der Typ, das muss man sich vorstellen...
Wenn, wenn das der Bersi ist...
Hier da, der Busch hier ist der Bersi...
Da stand einfach rum...
Und ich bin auf ihn zugelaufen und hab meine Crap-Taste gedrückt.
Der hat sich nicht bewegt.
Obwohl Bersi eigentlich somit die besten Movement-Fähigkeiten hat.
Das war echt...
Das hab ich so nicht, das hab ich noch nicht gesehen.
Ich weiß noch, was das für einer war, keine Ahnung.
Was ist das eigentlich für ein Icon?
Ah, das ist mein Pet, ne?
Vor allem, warum wird das...
Wo geht das weg, wenn man da draufklickt?
Wähle Gaben als Präsident und es wird keinen dritten Weltkrieg geben.
Der Witz ist nicht schlecht.
Erinnert sich noch jemand an den Half-Life 2 Source Code?
Diebstahl?
Äh...
D-Link HD...
Hi...
Ähm...
Hab...
Hab gerade dein Video gesehen, war alles echt...
Ne, Moment.
Ich...
Ich kann nicht lesen.
Äh...
Ich bin R.I.P.
Reading Skills.
Hab gerade dein Meltdown-Video gesehen, war alles echt gut erklärt.
Meine Frage jetzt.
Wie denkst du, wird sich jetzt der Markt entwickeln bezüglich Internet und AMD?
Der Internet-Chef hat ja schon...
Der Internet-Chef hat ja schon einige Aktien verkauft.
Ähm...
Ich glaube, das wird erstmal keinen großen Unterschied machen.
Die Anwendung, wo Intel aktuell schneller ist, wird Intel wahrscheinlich auch schneller bleiben.
Äh, also bei der aktuellen Generation.
Trotz...
Trotz diesem Bug jetzt.
Es sei denn, es sind irgendwelche grenzwertigen Sachen wie Datenbanken oder so.
Mounting Skills.
Dann nicht.
Für die...
Für die Zukunft...
Also, wenn...
Wenn AMD da jetzt noch ein bisschen oben drauf legt...
Also, ich glaube nicht, dass es so viele Einflüsse haben wird, ehrlich gesagt.
Glaube, das wird die Welt sehr schnell vergessen.
Nein, das wird die Welt nicht vergessen.
Ähm...
Die Welt wird zwar vergessen, dass es da mal eine Sicherheitslücke und Probleme gegeben
hat, aber die Welt wird schlechte Benchmark-Ergebnisse weiterhin sehen für Intel-CPUs.
Je nach Benchmark.
Ja?
Je nachdem, was die Benchmarks machen.
Und ich...
Ich hoffe jetzt mal, dass, ähm...
Einige Seiten vielleicht den ein oder anderen Benchmark reinnehmen, der syscall-intensiver
ist.
Und wenn man das macht, dann sieht man in Zukunft immer weiter, dass Intel beschissenere Benchmark-Ergebnisse
hat.
Ja, vollkommen zu Recht dann.
Centaur Bash.
Schlechte Benchmarks, MonkaS.
Ja, ja.
Wenn man jetzt mal...
Angenommen, man macht einen Datenbank-Benchmark oder sowas, was ja gar nicht mal so abwegig
ist, ja?
Das testet I.O., testet CPU-LAS, alles Mögliche.
Kann man ja machen.
Dort könnte es durchaus sein, dass AMD, auch wenn sie vielleicht normalerweise jetzt
langsamer gewesen wären, Intel abhängen werden.
Zu einem günstigeren Preis.
Weißt du zufällig den Real-World-Use-Case, der sehr syscall-intensiv ist?
Ehe Datenbanken zum Beispiel.
Also, syscalls...
Im Prinzip sind syscalls ja alles, wo du mehr Rechte brauchst.
Ja, also sei es jetzt Zugriff auf Netzwerk und I.O. und sowas in der Richtung.
Du brauchst ja für fast alles einen syscall.
Was jetzt halt nicht rein...
rein User-seitig zu berechnen ist.
Also Spiele haben da die wenigsten Probleme mit.
Moment.
Ich lauf übelst...
übelst hängen.
Wo lauf ich denn eigentlich lang, ey?
Da muss ich hin.
Ja, also Datenbank ist so ein Szenario.
Könnte ich mir gut vorstellen.
Kann das sein, dass ich grad übelst die Orientierung irgendwie verloren hab?
Ich lauf...
Ich lauf jetzt einfach hier dem.
So.
Ja, ich bin in die falsche Richtung gerannt.
Auf den Berg hoch?
Da?
Ja.
Bergstellt.
Die erste richtig gute Erklärung, die ich gefunden habe.
Ja, finde ich nämlich auch.
Ich will...
Also wie gesagt, so Eigenlob stinkt und sowas in der Richtung.
Aber das ist der Grund, warum ich das Video gemacht hab.
Ich hab ganz...
Die meisten Einträge auf den News-Seiten waren einfach Kacke.
Die haben alles in einen Topf geschrieben.
Und alle haben nur geschrieben, oh, das ist schlimm und oh, das hat irgendwas mit Speicheradressen
zu tun und irgendwie sowas.
Aber so wirklich, was das Problem ist, das hat kaum eine News-Seite geschrieben.
Und ich hab auch auf YouTube mal ein paar Videos geguckt.
Die haben auch alle mehr oder weniger nur das vorgelesen.
Die hatten schlicht und ergreifend alle keine Ahnung, wovon sie eigentlich reden.
Und ich hab mir gedacht, hey, komm, das kann doch nicht sein, dass ich der Einzige bin,
den interessiert, was da eigentlich genau passiert.
Deswegen hab ich das Video auch gemacht.
Jetzt werden Mini-Centaurs gebasht.
Die nur da sind, dass Noobs, die nach Grand Bazaar reiten, nicht geownt werden.
Der X-Man.
Da ist er.
Ich hoffe, euch gefällt heute auch mal ein bisschen entspanntere Musik.
Weiß einer von euch eigentlich, ob wirklich exklusiv Intel betroffen ist?
Also, bei AMD ist es ziemlich sicher, dass sie nicht davon betroffen sind.
Sie sagen, sie führen sowas nicht out of order aus.
Was quasi andere Privileg erfordert.
Ähm, ARM, keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Es war jetzt nicht unbedingt richtig, es war jetzt nicht wirklich Intel-spezifisch.
Also, da ist jetzt nichts drinnen, wo man sagt, hey, das ist was, wo man ganz einfach
Intel-interne Sachen für kennen muss oder so.
Es ist eher bei AMD einfach besser implementiert.
Also, das kann durchaus sein, dass ARM das gleiche Problem hat.
Ich wollte eigentlich auf den Berg hoch, fällt mir so auf.
Kommt auch noch ein Video zu Spectre?
Nee.
Ist ihr, wie lange ich gebraucht hab, bis ich gecheckt habe, was da eigentlich genau passiert?
Also, ich mein, das ist die eine Sache, ob man versteht prinzipiell, was die schreiben.
Und es dann auch irgendwie...
Und es dann auch irgendwie in Zusammenhang bringt.
Also...
Es ist jetzt ja auch nicht wirklich so simpel.
Was ist mit dem los, ey?
Piss dich, Alter.
Es laggt.
Mega lag.
Wo lauf ich hier eigentlich grad hin?
Total beknackt, ich sollte...
Es laggt.
Ultra lag, ey.
Was ist denn das?
PTF?
Warum laggt das so?
Ich lauf jetzt mal zum Spot und guck mal, irgendjemand hat was im Chat noch geschrieben.
Du hast ja gesagt, die meisten Patches werden die Tabelle aus den Prozessen rausnehmen.
Könnten die Prozesse nicht einfach die Adressen bruteforcen?
Wenn die dann eine passende Adresse finden würden, wäre das immer noch...
Nee, können sie nicht.
Können sie nicht.
Weil der Teil, der virtuelle Adressen zu echten Adressen auflöst, kennt.
Diese Adressen für diesen Prozess nicht.
Das bringt dir nix, wenn du es durchprobierst.
Du kannst alle deine virtuellen Adressen ausprobieren.
Diese Adressen werden nie für deinen Prozess aufgelöst.
Zu echten Adressen.
Nie.
Weil es nicht drinnen steht.
Weil es nicht gemappt ist.
Man macht es ja hauptsächlich aus Performance-Gründen.
Dass man es eben in jedem Prozess mappt, allerdings nur den Zugriff verbietet.
Das ist ja auch irgendwo sinnvoll.
Da musst du nicht jedes Mal dein ganzes Zeug umschreiben und löschen.
Allerdings halt nur, wenn du den Zugriff verbietest.
Das ist ja auch irgendwo sinnvoll.
Da musst du nicht jedes Mal dein ganzes Zeug umschreiben und löschen.
Da musst du nicht jedes Mal den Zugriff flourpen.
Nee, dasر du족bthae luiatärden.
Nja, aber verdammt.
Also, nicht, weil.
Ja, ja, aber compatible.
Das ist das Problem, der injos
advocate &
dash
Souc
auch nicht auf Speicher von anderen Prozessen, genau.
Und deswegen muss
ja auch bei jedem Context-Switch,
wenn dein Prozessor
halt jetzt einen anderen Prozess bearbeitet oder
einen anderen Thread bearbeitet, muss dieses
ganze Ding dann ausgetauscht werden.
Diese ganze
Auflösungstabelle muss dann ausgetauscht
werden. Das dauert halt, weil
um für den nächsten Prozess
die Tabelle quasi zu laden,
musst du deine
kompletten
gespeicherten Tabellen für alle Prozesse
durchgehen und die zusammenbauen und dann
reinschreiben und dann switchen.
Deswegen ist ja ein Context-Switch auch so teuer
und wird jetzt noch teurer.
Früher waren halt wenigstens
Kernel-Aufrufe ziemlich billig dadurch.
Weil in jedem Prozess einfach das gleiche
reingemappt war und da musste nichts umgeschrieben werden,
sondern nur das für den jeweiligen Prozess.
Dafür jetzt aber dazu.
Serious Max, was ist so das
Ergebnis?
Bei den Benchmarks... Also wenn ich
ohne dass ich mir angeguckt habe, ich vermute mal,
dass bei Games wahrscheinlich sich das
in der Messungenauigkeit bewegt.
Vielleicht bei den ein oder anderen Spielen,
wenn man die auf niedrige Details stellt
und quasi maximal
CPU-Auslastung provoziert, dann minimal
also wirklich minimal
würde ich jetzt erwarten bei Spielen.
Bei so Sachen
wie Prime 95 und sowas
würde ich sagen, gar nichts.
Null.
Das Ding rechnet ja rein
User-seitig.
Und halt bei
I.O.-intensiveren Sachen. Also auf
File-Servern und sowas würde ich sagen, hat man
ein bisschen Einbußen.
Fast absolut gleich, ja.
Würde mich auch wundern, wenn nicht.
Das sind wirklich Grenzfälle, wo du
da großartig Performance-Einbußen durch hast.
Also die Regel
ist es nicht.
Wisst ihr, was das Beste ist? Morgen ist Freitag.
Das ist sehr, sehr nice.
So, ähm...
Übrigens, wenn jemand noch andere Themen hat,
könnt ihr gerne in den Chat schreiben.
Also ich muss mich jetzt nicht da
den ganzen Abend über das Zeug auslassen.
Vergiss nicht, dann eine Box zu sellen.
Ah ja, stimmt. Ja, muss ich noch machen.
Da muss ich mir Level 1 Mystik erstellen.
Das mache ich jetzt.
Machen wir jetzt gleich noch.
Mache ich mir ein Mystik. Level 14 Mystik.
Ja, das mache ich jetzt gleich nach der Daily hier.
Level 14 Mystik erstellen
und Box sellen.
Stich Box beim Wizard hier.
Nee, ne?
Ja.
Also...
Andere... Andere Themen.
Vorsätze in 2080. Keine Vorsätze.
Das bringt nichts.
Ich finde, dieses ganze...
Dieses Vorsätze zu Jahresbeginn ist eigentlich verkehrt.
Wenn man irgendwie was merkt,
was scheiße ist und man hat...
Ähm...
Also man hat verstanden, dass man das ändern sollte
und hat auch quasi so die...
So die Überzeugung, dass das gut ist,
wenn man das ändert, dann ist es ja bescheuert,
darauf zu warten, bis das Jahr anfängt.
Man kann damit einfach anfangen.
Ich meine, es gibt genug Sachen,
von denen man weiß, dass es nicht gut ist,
aber man hat nicht genug Antrieb,
sie zu ändern. Das wird halt
der Jahresanfang 2018 auch nicht ändern.
Also zum Beispiel
eine Sache, die ich letztes Jahr
gemerkt habe... Ich meine, ich werde auch
nicht jünger, ne? Aber
man muss auf der anderen Seite sagen, so 33 ist jetzt ja auch
nicht kurz vorm Abkratzen, aber das ist schon
so ein Alter, wo man manche Sachen
mehr merkt, die man halt früher nicht so gemerkt hat.
Zum Beispiel, dass
wenn ich lange vorm Rechner sitze, dass mir der Rücken weh tut
und sowas. Hatte ich früher auch alles nicht.
Ich habe halt gemerkt, wenn ich auf der Arbeit den ganzen
Tag rumhocke, und ich habe jetzt da
glücklicherweise so einen krassen Steh-Schreibtisch,
also auf der Arbeit
unterheim, wenn ich den ganzen Tag auf der Arbeit
rumhocke, plus halt
noch konzentriert auf den Rechner gucke,
plus daheim dann quasi noch
am Rechner was mache,
das auf Dauer habe ich da...
bekommt mir das nicht so gut.
Deswegen habe ich mich jetzt dazu
durchgerungen, dass ich jetzt
morgens und abends
quasi früher
aussteige und auf die Arbeit laufe,
beziehungsweise von der Arbeit zurück zum Bahnhof laufe.
Das sind so ungefähr,
ja, wenn du langsam bist,
35 bis 40 Minuten, aber da muss es
schon wirklich langsam sein. Normal läufst du eher eine halbe Stunde.
Da hast du... da bin ich halt
morgens mal ein bisschen, ein bisschen, wenigstens...
Bin ich gerade in die
Wüste gelaufen?
Ja. Bin ich halt morgens mal wenigstens eine halbe
Stunde unterwegs und mittags. Und das hat schon was gebracht.
Wisst ihr, also was ich halt gemerkt
habe, ist dadurch, wenn ich mich so richtig wenig bewegt
habe und viel vom Rechner gesessen habe, was halt auch nicht
ausbleibt, wenn man eben sowas arbeitet
wie ich und jetzt noch YouTube und Twitch
und Gedöns macht,
was ich gemerkt habe, ist irgendwie, dass ich...
Das ist ganz, ganz, ganz
schwierig zu beschreiben. Ich war viel
unaufmerksamer und
es ist schwierig zu beschreiben.
So ein bisschen, so ein bisschen, so wie als...
als ist man so ein bisschen
benommen im Kopf. Wisst ihr?
Weiß nicht, ob die Beschreibung... ob die Beschreibung...
jetzt so gut passt. Als ist man irgendwie ein bisschen benommen
im Kopf und nicht so richtig bei der Sache
und als... so, so, so ein bisschen
so, als ist man so ein bisschen benebelt
einfach, ja.
So, und seit ich da das
wenigstens jetzt hin und
zurücklaufen mache jeden Tag,
auch bei Wind und Wetter, und das habe ich
auch nicht so 2018 angefangen, sondern
als ich halt gemerkt habe,
dass es was bringt.
Vorsatz war halt gewesen, ich mache weiter,
aber das hätte ich auch so ohne 2018
gemacht.
Deswegen, ich denke, Vorsatz brauchen wir nicht.
Wie war dein Silvester?
Geh mal oben bei mir aufs Profil und in Videos.
Da siehst du, was ich
an Silvester gemacht habe.
Wie kommt es, dass du jetzt BDO streamst? Kommt das öfters?
Das kam ja schon relativ oft.
Das ist super entspannt.
Ich kann endlich mal wieder
mit dem Fabian was zusammenspielen.
Und das Game ist ja auch nicht übel.
So, ich muss jetzt noch
ein 14er Mystic machen.
BDO ist auch echt entspannt zum Anschauen, ja, finde ich.
Max, was sagst
du denn zu den Sicherheitslücken
von Intel?
Warst du heute schon mal bei YouTube
bei mir auf dem Channel?
Imori.
Max, wegen dir habe ich
wieder mit BDO angefangen.
Weswegen hast du
dann aufgehört?
Weil das Game ist halt auch nicht für jeden was.
Warst du noch nicht bei mir auf YouTube? Ja, geh mal
bei mir auf YouTube gucken, weil ich habe
dazu heute was hochgeladen.
Wo krebs ich hier eigentlich rum?
Das ist der
uneffektivste Cry in aller Zeiten
hier. Der Fabian kriegt wahrscheinlich
Anfälle, wenn er das sieht, wie ich hier die einzelnen Mobs
bashe. Das ist nicht
optimized genug.
Ich wusste, Fabian,
ich wusste es, ich wusste es.
Ich kenne dich, ich wusste, dass du dich aufregst.
Ich kann mir das so richtig
vorstellen.
Swift Rage.
Den da.
Ups.
Dahin.
Okay. Ja, dann bashe ich
dann da noch 100 Bersas.
Ja, Bersas
vielleicht auch.
Centaurs.
Und dann machen wir uns in Mystic auf Level
14, das dauert 15 Minuten oder so.
Bringen sie nach Velia
und machen die
Awakening Box auf und sellen das Ding dann.
Für Money.
Easy Money.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Emori, du musst deinen CPU nicht zurückschicken.
Das ist, äh,
ergibt eigentlich
wenig Sinn. Also ich meine,
es gibt jetzt ja Patches für Windows und so
und die Geschwindigkeitseinbußen
halten sich echt in Grenzen.
Vor allem für Spiele dürften sie kaum
existieren. Allerdings auf der anderen
Seite,
ähm,
ist halt ein 7700
alte, alte
Generation, also.
Vielleicht kaufst du dir lieber
einen 8700.
Jetzt unabhängig von Meltdown,
der ist auch von Meltdown betroffen.
Aber ist die bessere
CPU, weil 6 Kerne
und neue Generation.
Und ich glaub preislich nimmt sich's gar nicht so viel.
Brauchst halt auch ein neues
Mainboard, teureres Mainboard.
Aber wenn es nur wegen Meltdown
ist,
würd ich es nicht zurückschicken.
Spart man die Sharkatozis lieber
oder was holt man sich davon?
Wollten wir ne Dande-Box holen.
Aber hast gestern ne Tri-Dande gesniped.
Äh, keine Ahnung, was man sich dann
davon holen sollte, wenn man ne Dande schon hat.
Ähm, aber ich würd's auf jeden Fall aufheben,
weil von den ersten,
wir können ja gleich nochmal gucken, was es da gibt.
Aber die ersten paar Sachen waren soweit ich weiß
nicht sonderlich toll. Auch das Pferd nicht.
Dann lieber irgendwie, äh,
abgecraten Schmuck
oder sowas.
Ich werd mir in 14 Tagen
ne Dande holen für'n Wizard.
Wenn ich die nicht vorher noch irgendwie
gesniped kriege.
Glaub ich aber nicht.
Dev, da sind sie ausgewischt in die Bar.
Warum sag ich eigentlich die Basis? Das sind überhaupt nicht
die Basis.
Halt BDO-Mobs. Alles gleiche.
Ich würd jetzt aber
nicht quasi, also wenn ich mir jetzt
nen Rechner zusammengestellt hätte,
würd ich nicht jetzt das ändern und
großartig, vor allem wenn's für Gaming ist, weil
ähm, wenn ich mich für'n 8000
700k zum Beispiel entschieden hab,
bringt es nix zu sagen, hey, deswegen, wegen
Meltdown hol ich mir jetzt nen AMD, weil
man hat sich ja bewusst dafür entschieden
für'n 8700k, weil er
in Games schneller ist als AMD und
das ist ja immer noch.
Okay, die Rotation ist zu klein.
Wo rotier'
ich denn hier am besten?
Das hab ich ganz vielen Leuten auch unter den
Videos auf YouTube gesagt, ne? Viele haben
gesagt, oh, ich hol mir jetzt nen 7700,
weil 8700 nicht lieferbar
ist. Ich finde, das ist eine der
wenigen Situationen, wo es
Sinn gemacht hat, tatsächlich
mal zu warten mit dem Hardwarekauf.
Normalerweise sag ich ja, kauft euch immer
das, wenn ihr was braucht, allerdings
geht's ja dann meistens darum, dass man nicht drauf warten
soll, bis irgendwas Neues vorgestellt wird und
ne, aber das war ja schon
vorgestellt und man wusste ja quasi
was Sache ist und dass es besser ist.
Und da hätte man schon mal
ne Woche warten können oder, oder nen Monat.
Aber
ein 7700 ist natürlich
immer noch super CPU.
So, einmal noch rauf,
dann müssten wir alle haben.
Quest abgeben, oder Level
14 müsste ich erstellen.
Oder Fabian, was meinst? Level 14
macht Sinn, oder? War ich auf
Level 14, dann haben wir theoretisch noch ne Felsdeck-Chart.
Weil, ob ich
jetzt Level 14 mache,
oder ob ich direkt nach Velia renne, macht jetzt
ja zeitlich auch keinen allzu großen Unterschied.
Das dauert 15 Minuten.
Eats as fuck.
Lit, lit und eats as fuck.
Ich glaube, ich hab
heute auf der Arbeit einen verwirrt. Der ist schon ein bisschen
älter, muss man sagen, und hat's auch nicht mit so
mit so Internet-Slang ausdrücken.
Und er hat mich heute angeschrieben und hat so
gemeint, hier Max, wo ist dann das Test-System
dafür? Da hab ich gesagt, das Test-System
gibt's nicht mehr, das haben die Typen kaputt gemacht, denen das
gehört. Und, äh, ist
halt weg und gibt's demnächst auch nicht mehr. Hat er halt
so gemeint, ja und, wo soll ich das jetzt testen?
Etwa auf dem Live-System?
Da hab ich halt gar nichts draufgeschrieben, hab einfach nur gesagt
YOLO. Und dann hat er dann
nichts mehr geantwortet, also null,
ja, null geantwortet.
Und irgendwann, als ich ihn später
gesehen hab, hat er mich so ganz komisch
angeguckt, irgendwie so, äh,
was wolltest du eigentlich jetzt von mir?
Da kann man halt Leute noch
mit verwirren, mit sowas.
Ich mein, YOLO, YOLO ist mittlerweile
die Abkürzung, kennt doch jeder.
Moin, Schisibro.
Ja, die neuen CPUs gehen nur mit
Z370. Es kommt irgendwann
demnächst jetzt, und demnächst ist
dehnbar bei Intel, wissen wir ja.
Ähm, auch wahrscheinlich eine bisschen günstigere
Plattform dafür.
Aber, da würde
ich jetzt beispielsweise nicht drauf fahren.
Es gibt doch auch relativ günstige.
Also ich mein, du kriegst um die 120 Euro schon
ein super Z370 Board.
Das ist zwar immer noch teuer im Vergleich
zu anderen Mainboards, aber dafür hat man ja
best ever.
Wer braucht schon einen neuen
Job? Wieso ich benutze auf der Arbeit
total viel Internet-Slang
und so.
Ich dachte auch manchmal geflamed
und sowas. Das gucken sie
manchmal immer. Hä, was will er denn jetzt wieder?
Ich dachte Overwatch heute, wer sagt denn sowas?
Hab ich das
gesagt?
Ich hab Placement schon gemacht.
8 zu 2.
Und ich hab festgestellt,
was stand auf YouTube?
Hä?
Ich hab auf YouTube heute
nicht gepostet, dass
ich...
Ich bin verwirrt.
Ich hab auf YouTube heute nichts gepostet, dass ich Overwatch
streame. Hast du vielleicht
einen Post gesehen, der
ein bisschen älter ist?
Kann das sein?
Weil das letzte, was ich gepostet hab, war gestern,
dass heute das Lootboxen-Video kommt.
Das Lootboxen-Video kam heute aber nicht,
weil ich das über Intel-CPUs machen
wollte.
Das hab ich vor zwei Wochen geschrieben mit
Overwatch ranked.
Ne, ne, ne, Max.
Die Leute, glaub ich, die haben sich da
mittlerweile schon eingestellt, dass ich da
sehr viel Internet-Zeugs laber.
Ich sag ja auch manchmal
sowas flamed euch nicht.
Aber die meisten
sind ja auch ein bisschen jünger und spielen selbst.
Hast du mal Final Fantasy gespielt?
Ich hab sau viele Final Fantasy schon gespielt.
So, jetzt machen wir uns ein Mystic.
Mystic bis Level 14.
Nicht Endgame.
Mystic bis Level 14,
um Dunde-Box zu verkaufen.
Ease as fuck.
Warst du schon mal im Darknet?
Oh, das ist wieder so eine Frage.
Im Prinzip,
ich hab schon Tor verwendet, aber ich hab
jetzt nicht explizit nach irgendwelchen illegalen Sachen
da geguckt.
So, äh.
Hab ich Dunde-Box gesagt? Nee.
Äh.
Denkst, blaue Box. Dunde wär schön, ja.
Wenn ich Dunde-Box hätte.
Das...
Ja. So. Mystic.
Wo isser? Wo isser?
Wo ist das Mystic-Grill?
Da isser.
Diese Anzeigen hier unten erinnern
mich irgendwie an die Waffen-Stats
in Call of Duty früher.
Die sind wahrscheinlich genauso
fail. Was steht denn beim Wizard da?
Äh. Wo isser denn?
Haben die eigentlich
das gleiche?
Ich...
Ich glaube...
Ich glaube Pearl Abyss, weil die wissen selber nicht,
was sie da eintragen.
So. Was steht beim Wizard?
Ah, der Wizard ist jetzt auch standardmäßig jung,
wie es aussieht.
Aha. Was auch immer.
Äh. Okay. Create.
Level 14 Mystic.
So.
Machen wir jetzt gar nicht viel Zeugs
hier, sondern
Charakter-Name.
Ähm.
Debated. Overrated.
So. Moment.
Wollen wir jetzt den Held nochmal an?
Ey. Dieses Menü hier
ist übelst... Moment. Kann man nicht
Overrated schreiben?
Das ist zu lang. Fuck!
Ah. Moment.
Debated. Outdated. Ist besser.
Ja. Boop-Physik.
Aber das ist... Das muss...
Das ist ein koreanisches
beziehungsweise asiatisches MMO.
Da ist das das Erste,
was irgendwie geht.
Und in BDO ist es ja noch
halbwegs realistisch. Ja. Nicht wie in anderen
Videos.
Tommy, es gibt Sachen, das
muss man nicht unbedingt jedem
außer Auge drücken. Nein, nein. Kein Tutorial.
Please, please. Kein Tutorial.
No.
Debated.
Was?
Oh. Starting NPC
soll ich finden. Egal. Ich bashe jetzt erstmal
ein paar Mobs. Lul.
Friend Request?
What?
Warum inviten mich grad random einfach Leute?
Wahrscheinlich aus dem Stream.
So.
Weasel.
Okay.
Ja. Fabian, das ist wirklich ganz
schlimm.
Also wie gesagt, ich werd jetzt auch nur noch
Womin sagen.
Anstatt Womin.
Weil alles andere ist sonst
zu sexistisch.
So. Jetzt machen wir mal mein typisches Gequeste.
Einfach so schnell wie es geht.
Der Bund. Next.
Sinnlose Killtasks machen.
Also jetzt seht ihr mal, für alle, die
irgendwie auch neu bei BDO sind, wie
einfach das Leveln ist. Ich mein nicht, dass
die ersten 14 Level in MMOs
sonderlich schwierig sind. Aber
das ist mittlerweile mega schnell. Guck mal. Bam.
Level 6.
Guck mal. Seht ihr,
wie die XP da hoch springt?
Zwei Mobs gekillt, schon Level 6.
Nein.
Ah.
Ja, bis Stone Chamber.
Ich weiß. Die Musik ist grad ein bisschen
kaputt.
Ja, ich mach die Main Quest bis 14.
Das geht halt übelst schnell.
Snacks.
Der erste, der mal das PC-Kommando
auf Anhieb weiß und
benutzt.
Ansonsten kommen ja dann
Ausrufezeichen HW,
Hardware, Specs
oder sonst was. Aber Ausrufezeichen PC.
So ist richtig.
Foxes bashen.
Ausrufezeichen V-Balls.
Irgendwann mach ich mal
Ich hab noch so G2A
Cards mit Codes
drauf, wo man sich dann was kaufen kann.
Da mach ich ja irgendwann mal Raffle-Stream.
Dann gehen sie alle ab.
Ausrufezeichen Raffle. Lol.
Das wollte ich schon
immer mal, dass das die Leute bei mir spammen.
Das mach ich auch bei jeder Gelegenheit.
Nicht, weil es was gibt, sondern weil es halt
wenn man damit schön
trollen kann irgendwie.
Ausrufezeichen Raffle.
Auf
Ich hab geride klickt.
Ich ride klicke immer noch.
Next.
Warum krieg ich jetzt auf einmal so viele
Views? Denken sie alle ich mach jetzt
Mystic Reroll?
Oder hab ich irgendwie nen Host gekriegt oder sowas?
Moment muss ich mal nachgucken.
Hat mich irgendjemand gehostet?
Nö.
Kommen doch grad irgendwie viele und wollen
meinen Level 14 Mystic sehen.
Den ich nur angelegt hab für
Failstacks und Box verkaufen.
Next.
Bashen.
Bam Bam Bam.
Das klatschen muss das Leute.
Klatschen muss das.
Mystisch.
Kann man mit ner 1050 TI
60 FPS 720p streamen?
CPU
Encoding easy.
Easy kannst du das machen.
Je nach CPU kannst du auch
CPU Encoding easy machen.
Was ich sogar empfehlen würde, weil das sieht in der Regel besser aus.
Übrigens Leute.
Nächsten Stream
werde ich mal versuchen.
CPU Encoding easy zu streamen.
Das müsste ich eigentlich auf den gleichen Quality Settings
mit meiner CPU noch gut packen.
Ja moin an alle die neu sind.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen.
Bei eurem Max FPS.
Das Drönchen.
Macht der eigentlich noch?
Macht der Krieger noch Call of Duty Videos?
Ich hab lange nicht mehr geguckt.
Das letzte mal wo ich was gesehen hab hat er irgendwie
so nen Tauchgang gefilmt.
Hallo kann mich irgendein Deutscher hören?
Gibt's ja auch Pizza Giveaways.
Das mach ich irgendwann mal
wenn mich irgendein Pizzaladen sponsern will.
Die Quest sind so dumm.
Aber mit ner GTX 1060.
Äh wie gesagt.
Kommt drauf an ob du CPU Encoding machen willst.
Oder hast du das schon geschrieben?
Mit was willst du encoden?
Wenn du mit der Grafikkarte encoden willst
ist das überhaupt kein Ding.
Mit fast keiner.
Weil
da ist ein extra Encoder für drinnen.
Das ist für die Gaming Performance dann
kaum oder gar keine Beeinträchtigung.
Das haut da aber ganz schön
in die Tasten.
Hat man dich mittlerweile eigentlich mal gesehen Max?
In meinen Videos nicht.
In anderen Videos
bin ich ein bisschen im Hintergrund rumgelaufen.
Du hast was zu Jamie.
Ähm.
Ich glaub du hast was komplett falsch verstanden
wie ich das gemeint hab.
Mit was möchtest du deinen Stream encoden?
Nicht coden.
Möchtest du das mit der Grafikkarte machen?
Oder möchtest du das mit der CPU machen?
Das ist im Endeffekt in OBS
einfach nur
ein anderes Häkchen setzen.
GPU Encoding
ist halt
für die Performance
besser.
Sieht schlechter aus.
Und ja gut.
CPU Encoding ist umgedreht.
100 Euro Donation.
Vor allem
wenn du das donaten würdest.
Du weißt es ja eh schon.
Außerdem
ähm
wenn du das donaten würdest
dann würde es gar nichts geben.
Weil ich glaube ich krieg noch Geld.
Mach dir mal Gedanken.
Kannst du dich noch dran erinnern
ähm
ob wir das alles jetzt
ob das alles geklärt ist
oder ob da noch was offen ist.
Ich glaube nämlich wir haben das das letzte mal verschoben
äh
wegen anderen
Sachen.
Und ich krieg noch was.
Da müssen wir mal drüber labern dann.
Im Discord.
Ich kann mich nämlich auch nicht mehr so richtig dran erinnern.
Inkasso FPS.
Ne eher
mal so nach 2 Jahren Geldkrieg
FPS.
Also wie gesagt ob wir das jetzt heute oder morgen machen
ist ja auch nicht so wild.
Wir müssen uns da mal zusammen Gedanken drüber machen.
Und ich muss mal
ich guck mal auf Kontoauszügen ob ich irgendwas finde.
Ich glaube 100 Euro.
Ach keine Ahnung.
Lass einfach morgen nochmal oder irgendwann überlegen.
Da kommen wir bestimmt wieder drauf.
Also ich glaube auch da war noch was offen.
So haben wir es jetzt hier bald.
Moment.
Was mache ich denn hier?
Das ist total Blödsinn.
Ja wie gesagt du weißt ja ich merk mir das auch nicht.
Ah da fällt uns schon wieder ein.
So.
Jetzt gehen wir zur Princess of
Serendia.
Da ist sie.
Warum haben wir die jetzt genau hier gesetzt?
Diarette.
Ey es hört sich irgendwie
ein bisschen an wie Jogurette finde ich.
Right Click.
Nope. Nicht Right Click.
R-Click.
So. Easy.
Schon sind wir fertig.
Das war's. Mehr muss man nicht machen.
Es ist jetzt dennoch hier die
Ah diese eine Quest. Mehr muss man nicht machen.
Wenn man sich einen neuen Char erstellt.
Für Felsdecks und für
Gedöns was man so braucht in Velia.
Aber bis zu
dieser Quest muss man was machen.
Weil ab dieser Quest kann man erst enchanten.
Bist du nicht der Sachse.
Der Osten meldet sich zurück.
Ne der Thorsten meldet sich zurück.
Ja stimmt ja.
Ganz
durcheinander gefragt.
Ich bin nicht der Sachse.
Ich hör mich doch absolut 06ig
an oder?
Ach mein Kollege.
Da meldet sich der Osten.
Zurück.
Beatport. Nein das ist mein
richtig aktueller PC
auf dem ich hier gerade spiele und streame.
Der ist doch geil
der PC. Da kann man überhaupt nichts dagegen sagen.
Also die Komponenten sind
wirklich aller erste Sahne. Was besseres
wirst du zum Spielen nicht finden.
Aktuell.
Über den RGB Rahmen kann man sich streiten.
So jetzt haben wir die Quest.
Dann rennen wir jetzt mal nach Velia.
Und verkaufen die Box.
Autorun. Moment warte.
Ah Autorun
nicht gemappt. Ok.
RGB Rahmen
triggert schon immer.
Ganz ehrlich es gibt so viel unsinnige
Sachen mit RGB Beleuchtung mittlerweile.
Da ist RGB Rahmen
noch die die zwar genauso
unsinnig ist wie alles andere.
Aber die sitzt wenigstens schön zentral im Rechner
und kann dann alles beleuchten.
Dann brauchst du nur eine Sache mit RGB Beleuchtung.
Weiß jemand wie man
Geld über das Schattengrab bekommt?
Finde dazu nichts
und will das Drecksfragezeichen
endlich wegbekommen.
Ich weiß doch nicht mal wo das Schattengrab ist.
Ich kann dir
einen Tipp geben.
Was ganz praktisch ist.
Wenn du das Game auf Englisch stellst
kriegst du den Begriff
raus wie das auf Englisch heißt.
Falls du schon gegoogelt hast
nichts gefunden hast.
Stell das Game auf Englisch.
Guck dir an wie der Begriff auf Englisch heißt.
Es gibt das in Google ein.
Dann findest du es gibt eigentlich
für jeden Ort für jeden NPC
für jede Quest für BDO
eine Seite
wo du dann sehen kannst was du machen musst.
Könntest du eventuell
nochmal ein Video zu dem 120, 144,
165, 240 Hz Monitor machen?
Habe ich gemacht.
Ich habe es aufgenommen.
Ich habe noch kein Video draus gemacht
und hatte eigentlich gar nicht vor das hochzuladen.
Und generell
es empfiehlt sich BDO auf Englisch zu spielen.
Also wenn dir das jetzt
irgendwie nicht liegt
oder du sagst es ist einfach angenehm
in Deutsch zu spielen
kann man das auch machen
aber man findet viele Sachen
viel viel einfacher wenn es auf Englisch ist.
Ich muss gerade mal was gucken nebenbei
während ich hier lang jogge.
Ok
So ein bisschen schneller hier.
Ist Mystic Grill.
Ein bisschen schneller rennen.
Ist zwischen
Watchtower und Klisch Swamp.
Mal gucken ob ich das habe.
Klisch war das hier unten.
Das da?
Ne.
Habe ich das?
Was du meinst?
Also Watchtower ist da und
Klisch Swamp ist da und dazwischen?
Dazwischen ist doch eigentlich gar nichts.
Ah Little Samus.
Achso da gibt es unterschiedliche Panels.
Also wenn das alles schnell genug ist
und du hast ein EPS Panel natürlich viel besser.
Also ist schon ein Unterschied.
Wenn es um die Blickwinkel Abhängigkeiten
sowas anbelangt.
Kann das sein das BDO ein bisschen hinterher ist?
Mit Weihnachten?
Sieht man nur auf der Minimap und nicht auf der großen Karte.
Ok dann keine Ahnung.
Dann muss man irgendwie bei wie heißt das
BDO Atlas Seite oder so gucken.
Ok
Dann gehen wir mal zum Vault holen
unsere Kiste raus und verkaufen es.
Ja
Beat Protester Typ sah wirklich gruselig aus.
So habe ich das
beim Berser drin oder wo habe ich diese
komische Awakening Kiste da rumliegen.
Mein Account ist so unordentlich.
Ich müsste das alles mal aufräumen.
Hier kommt mal Easy Shokato Seals.
Fünf noch
dann gibt es da eine Box.
Ich glaube ich habe es beim Bersi.
Ich glaube ich habe es auf dem Bersi.
So der Bersi. Hat es der Bersi hier noch
irgendwo liegen? Da. Da ist es.
Awakening Weapon Box.
Endlich mal ein Ort den du von BDO kennst.
Das coole an BDO ist
ähm.
Das alles halbwegs bevölkert ist.
Also das ist ein
Nach Velia kommst du halt sau schnell.
Aber nach Velia gehst du auch immer wieder hin.
Na 800 Euro
ist schon mal eine Hausnummer für ein Bildschirm.
Ich werde mir erst einen neuen Bildschirm kaufen.
Wenn es diese 4K
144Hz HDR
G-Sync Dinger gibt.
Die sind zwar schweineteuer aber dann hat man
wenigstens auch mal was ordentlich Neues.
Bisschen was wo sich das abgehängt.
Wo man das halt spürt.
So wird mal schön für 9 Millionen verkauft jetzt.
Musik ist vorbei.
Ich nehme mal was anderes an.
So.
Istings Register.
Max Preis.
Easy Money.
So.
Fertig.
Werden die IPS oder TN sein?
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Ich hoffe mal IPS.
Das ist dann auch mal ein bisschen Upgrade.
Der Scheiß soll 1800 Euro kosten.
0.
Muss ich mal gucken.
Ob ich da nicht
irgendeinen Deal aushandeln kann.
Mit Asus.
Dass ich so einen kriege und dann irgendwie
irgendwas damit mache.
Übrigens Leute.
Es heißt Asus.
Muss man auch nochmal dazu sagen.
Und nicht Asus.
Wie das die Amis sagen.
Das finden die nicht toll.
Asus ist ok.
Aber Asus finden sie am allerbesten.
So Leute.
Debated.
Wir sind fertig.
Alles gemacht was ich machen wollte.
Und ich muss ja auch
im Prinzip in einer halben Stunde schon pennen.
Gibt es irgendeinen den wir hosten können?
Mal her.
Ich guck gerade bei den Leuten die ich
abonniert habe ob es da irgendeinen gibt.
Ähm.
Kann man da hosten?
Sehe ich jetzt eigentlich
keinen von denen die ich abonniert habe.
Und die meisten die ich jetzt hosten könnte
haben eh schon 5000 Zuschauer.
Wie wäre es mit Social Sleeping.
Ähm.
Ist ja schon fast so.
Die Detox.
Asus sagt nein.
Ich.
Vermute Asus sagt nicht nein.
Also ich wollte
mit Asus ja schon mal was machen.
Und.
Ich hab da nichts gefunden.
Letztendlich.
Was ich haben möchte.
Das ist auch noch nie vorgekommen.
Da haben wir uns drauf geeinigt.
Wenn ich was finde.
Sag ich ihnen nochmal Bescheid.
Und jetzt ist es soweit.
Zielkrampf.
Zielkrampf können wir hosten.
Das machen wir.
Ok Leute ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten
Stream oder im nächsten Video.
Wenn ihr noch nicht auf Youtube gewesen seid.
Ähm.
Heute und mal ein neues Video angeguckt habt.
Dann könnt ihr mal gucken. Ich hab was hochgeladen.
Zur aktuellen Intel CPU Lücke.
Zum aktuellen Intel CPU Bug.
Und.
Falls ihr mich nur von Twitch kennt.
Dann guckt mal über Youtube vorbei.
Oder folgt mir auf Twitter.
Da gibt es auch immer die neuesten Sachen.
Und dummes Gelaber von mir.
Das heißt wem das hier nicht reicht.
Der kann sich auch noch die volle Ladung auf Youtube
oder auf Twitter geben.
Und ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen.
Macht es gut. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.